ganz genau dafür stehen wir hier an die
beschlussvorlage mal hier auf diesen
großen screen gezogen haben wir einfach
in der hand hier an wir gehen als einmal
durch es steht uns einiges bevor es
beginnt aber erst mal muss man sagen wie
man es kennt mit einer kurzen
stellungnahme zur lage ich glaube in
stellungnahmen ist vielleicht noch mal
ganz wichtig auch dass wir einmal wissen
worüber sprechen wir eigentlich warum
geht es bei omikron jetzt auch wieder so
weiter wie wir sie aus einem vergangenen
jahr auch gekannt haben der expertenrat
dieser 19-köpfige und so stets zu beginn
der beschlussvorlage und das wird dann
mutmaßlich am ende des corona gipfels im
beschluss auch so stehen sagt dass nikon
sich die infektion mit micon alle zwei
bis drei tage
verdoppelt dadurch dass wir ein tempo
was man bisher nicht kennt und das ist
der grund warum die experten da jetzt so
viel druck machen besonders entscheidend
jan daneben in diesem zusammenhang
dieser satz hier die stark steigenden
infektionszahlen und deren folgen kann
ein ausmaß erreichen dass die kritische
infrastruktur
eingeschränkt wird was genau ist da zu
erwarten genau die große sorge ist dass
die infektionsrate so schnell hoch
schnee das also so viele menschen sich
mit omikron comecon muss man dann ja
sagen infizieren das beispielsweise in
krankenhäusern nicht mehr richtig
gearbeitet werden kann weil zum beispiel
viele ärzte oder auch krankenschwestern
dann zu hause bleiben müssen aber dass
man beispielsweise auch nicht mehr
richtig einkaufen gehen kann weil zum
beispiel in den supermärkten dann viele
verkäuferinnen und kassierer fehlen also
ähnlich der beim thema polizei oder
feuerwehr also dass gewisse wichtige
punkte in diesem land dann nicht mehr so
funktionieren die sie eigentlich
funktionieren müssten dass es diese
sogenannte kritische infrastrukturen die
sorge ist groß dass wir dann spätestens
zu beginn des jahres da aus fell erleben
und damit dieses land in seinen
grundfesten nicht mehr richtig
funktionsfähig ist wie gesagt dass es
die sorge dass es so kommt dass es nicht
klar aber zumindest gibt es die sorgt
zumindest das will man jetzt verhindern
wir schon weiter in dieses papier hinein
hier wird noch einmal die wichtigkeit
der booster impfung hervorgehoben denn
es ist auch klar geworden durch viele
expertenmeinungen ja alleine nur zwei
impfungen reichen nicht aus um wirklich
stark zu entgegenzutreten der busse muss
her daher hier auch noch mal ganz klein
hat papier vorgearbeitet wie wichtig
nicht nur die ersten zwei kämpfen sind
sondern natürlich auch die booster
impfungen und deswegen auch hier nochmal
die betonung die impfkampagne soll
natürlich auch über weihnachten und
zwischen den jahren und an silvester
weiter vorangetrieben werden also die
sorge hier das über den feiertagen alles
brach liegt und keiner sich mehr impfen
lässt und erst mal die feiertage gibt es
auch das wird hier noch mal
hervorgehoben genauso wie die impfung
für die kinder genau wir sehen uns ja in
einigen bundesländern berlin
beispielsweise auch ein bundesland das
jetzt die dir dass du in denen den den
zeitraum zwischen der zweiten und der
dritten impfung noch mal wieder verkürzt
hat beispielsweise in berlin jetzt von
fünf auf drei monate verkürzt das heißt
schon drei monate nach der zweiten
impfung kann man dann den dritten pigs
die so genannte booster impfung bekommen
in nordrhein westfalen hat ja sogar
bereits gesagt nach vier wochen wäre das
möglich also man will die dauer den
zeitraum deutlich verkürzen um einen
noch besseren schutz zu gewährleisten
während du sprichst ja scroll ich meinen
hund willkommen zu den maßnahmen die wir
hier auch nochmal hervorgehoben haben
nämlich dass das sich jetzt in zukunft
wenn also dieses papier sogar durch geht
heute durch den gipfel ändern wird ganz
entscheidend hier punkt nummer sechs im
papier richtig und hier sehen wir auch
das ist gelb unterlegt was auf die
geimpften auch zukommt wir wissen ja
schon seit längerer zeit das hat ja auch
eine mpk eine
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz wien es
immer corona gipfel beschlossen dass es
kontakt beschränkung für die ungeimpften
gibt zweig ganz klar sie dürfen nicht
mehr einkaufen so wie sie wollen sie nur
um bestimmte leben und auch das
zusammentreffen in einer gruppe mit
ungeimpften bedeutet das eigentlich nur
noch ein haushalt +2 ungeimpfte
zusammenkommen dürfen und jetzt sehen
wir aber wenn das alles so kommt müssen
wir ja immer sagen und die
ministerpräsidenten und der
bundeskanzler das beschließen dann soll
ab dem 28
dezember auch eine neue kontakt
beschränkung für die geimpften gelten
und das könnte bedeuten dass wir dann
genau nur noch zusammenkommen dürfen mit
maximal zehn personen also das bedeutet
für silvester zum beispiel eine feier
mit maximal zehn personen wer jetzt auf
die idee kommt zu sagen ja dann feiere
ich nicht drin so einer feier draußen
auch da würde nichts bringen denn hier
steht auch das ganze gilt für private
treffen innen wie im außenbereich also
auch dort die begrenzung auf zehn und
das ist dann gern für kinder genauso
kinder 14 jahre zu geht das natürlich
nicht natürlich hier auch nochmal der
aufruf drin verantwortungsbewusst über
die feiertage hier nochmal zwei ganz
wichtige punkte die anstehen ist es hier
sehr gepusht clubs und diskotheken in
räume werden geschlossen das weiße also
es wird nicht mehr gefeiert und dann
kommen wir doch mal zu einem wichtigen
punkt überregionale sport kultur und
großveranstaltungen dann ohne zuschauer
genau so ist das wenn das alles so kommt
müssen immer sagen aber zu ihr genau
wisst dass der diskussionsstand und wir
wissen auch dass viele
ministerpräsidenten und augen sollten
das im bundeskanzleramt da schon sehr
sehr eng und nahe beieinanderliegen es
gibt ja in diesem corona gipfel immer
noch wie der diskussion auch der eine
der dann aus spricht und sagt geht mir
alles nicht weit genug der andere der
sache es geht mir alles viel zu weit
aber das ist was wir hören in diesem
fall nicht unbedingt so sondern da ist
man sich ziemlich einig und ein
wichtiger punkt ist auch die frage warum
eigentlich erst ab dem 28 dezember und
nicht beispielsweise ab morgen oder ab
heiligabend
man geht davon aus in den
expertenkreisen dass uns diese omikron
welle erst wirklich nach weihnachten
richtig treffen würden es gibt die sorge
dass wenn die maßnahmen jetzt schon
greifen wird und man sagt pass auf die
kontakt beschränkung die beginnen
bereits morgen das ist dann etwas eine
nach einem nachlassenden effekt über
silvester gibt und man schon wieder
laxer eigentlich vorangeht deswegen
versucht man erst später mit den
maßnahmen zu beginnen um dann aber dafür
effektiver sie umsetzen zu können mehr
geld ist geplant dass uns da noch mal
kurz durch rauschen entsteht keine
konkrete somit drin aber unterstützungen
werden weiterhin ausgebaut und es
handelt sich natürlich auch um
beschlüsse die bereits im zweiten
dezember beschlossen worden sind die
auch weitergeführt werden sollen hier
das große iks man kommt wieder zusammen
noch im januar datum bisher in der
beschlussvorlage jahren noch nicht klar
genau die große frage ist wenn wir das
sehen wird es bei diesem papier bleiben
oder wird es noch weitere punkte gehen
beispielsweise auch restaurant
schließungen mann hat heute morgen die
bundesbildungsministerin ja wieder
gehört die gesagt hat auch sie versucht
oder sie hofft dass es keine
schulschließungen geben wird aber das
klingt auch schon wieder anders
eigentlich ist man ja davon ausgegangen
dass es definitiv keine
schulschließungen mehr geben soll wir
wissen von politikern auch aus der ampel
koalition beispielsweise dem grünen
gesundheitsexperten janosch dahmen der
von einem lockdown auch schon wieder
spricht im neuen jahr also das wort
lockdown was bisher immer vermieden
wurde ist wieder in der diskussion wir
müssen ganz genau abwarten was da heute
passiert aber eins ist klar die
maßnahmen die werden auf jeden fall
verschärft so viel kann man jetzt schon
sagen meinem sohn wurden auf jeden fall
jetzt schon sicherheitshalber die
arbeitsunterlagen mit nach hause gegeben
für die weihnachtsferien für den fall
dass man nach weihnachten nicht in die
schule zurückkehren sich besorgt waren
präpariert aber es ist natürlich für die
schüler verheerend hand ging alle
alarmglocken los das ist das papier über
das wir sprechen über dieses papier
sprechen die bund und länder chefs heute
wir berichten natürlich den ganzen tag
hier live für sie